Mobile Task Forces, the renowned first line
of defense for the SCP Foundation.
Comprised of the organization's most highly
trained operatives, MTFs are the boots on
the ground dealing with anomalous threats
and containment breaches head-on.
It’s a dangerous job.
In fact, joining an MTF is widely considered
one of the most hazardous roles within the
entire Foundation.
One where every day brings with it a whole
host of unexpected threats… and a high number
of casualties.
So let’s take a look at how one of those
days goes.
6:00 AM
“Rise and shine, troops!” comes a gravel-voiced
yell louder than any alarm clock.
The very second that early morning call goes
out over the intercom, the members of MTF
Nu-7 are on their feet.
Climbing out of their bunks and quickly getting
into uniform, the operators file out of their
barracks and hastily make their way to the
mess hall.
Among them is the latest recruit to join this
particular task force, Private Killian Hess,
lines up to receive his breakfast behind his
new squad mates.
This all takes place before most of the Foundation
has even woken up.
Even though these MTF operatives would rely
on working as a team to keep each other alive,
there is little casual conversation.
Most of them are actually quite solemn as
they eat, aware of the inherent risk that
comes with their job.
Private Hess, receiving a briefing the previous
day, is paired with a more grizzled and much
older veteran of Nu-7, Lieutenant Patterson.
Upon sitting down next to his new senior officer,
Hess immediately asks what has the rest of
the unit feeling so down.
“Boy, you really are new,” Patterson scoffs.
“Look, rookie, we do what we do and watch
each other’s backs like good soldiers.
But make no mistake: you’re on the USS Enterprise
now, kid… and we’re the red shirts.”
8:00 AM
Following their breakfast and early start,
any MTF operatives that aren’t thrust into
immediate action are sent to their designated
basic training area.
Here they are presented with all manner of
intense assault courses, fighting rings for
hand-to-hand sparring, and a live ammo shooting
range to improve skills with weapon proficiency.
The SCP Foundation demands the highest level
of skill from its Mobile Task Forces, so regular
combat drills are an absolute necessity for
keeping their operators alert and ready to
take on all manner of threats.
For some of the more hot-headed MTF troops,
drills are a chance to cut loose, show off
their skills or challenge their squad mates
to beat each other’s fastest assault course
times or shooting range scores.
But to those that have been around longer,
and have the benefit of hindsight after multiple
catastrophic containment breaches, morning
training can feel like pretty inadequate preparation.
After all, the Foundation sends its MTFs out
to take on some of their most dangerous SCPs,
most of which have wild, unpredictable abilities.
How does Practising Krav Maga really help
prepare someone for a fight with a creature
that can warp reality around it?
And hitting motionless paper targets at a
range can seem a little redundant when some
anomalies are virtually bulletproof.
10:00 AM
Of course, this is the SCP Foundation, meaning
it doesn’t take long for some strange happening
to occur.
MTF Nu-7 are soon dispatched on their first
assignment, after the Foundation loses contact
with a site known to house a particularly
dangerous anomaly.
Nicknamed ‘Hammer Down’, the task force
Hess has found himself thrust into is usually
deployed as a direct result of incidents where
communication is lost with Foundation facilities,
and containment breaches are suspected to
have occurred.
Hopping aboard a high-speed transport, Private
Hess and the rest of Hammer Down are quickly
briefed on their mission.
At approximately 0900 hours the same day,
the Foundation lost contact with another pair
of their MTFs – Omega-59, aka Nechayeva's
Wolves, and Sigma-18, the Chess Masters.
Both were stationed at Armed Containment Complex
04, a secure location within the Russian Federation’s
Sakha Republic.
Patterson informs the rest of MTF Nu-7 that
they were to re-establish communication with
the site, and assess any potential danger.
Although, by the time the transport arrives
at Complex 04, it becomes pretty clear that
things aren’t looking good.
SCP-1984 has breached containment: the Dead
Hand is loose.
Unluckily for Hammer Down, SCP-1984 is a semi-corporeal
entity with the nasty habit of attacking any
human being that it comes into contact with,
by disrupting their nervous systems, usually
resulting in excruciating pain.
Although that did answer the question of what
had happened to the other MTFs at the site…
12:00 PM
Immediately engaging the Dead Hand, Hammer
Down stormed Complex 04.
Patterson had ordered them to go weapons hot
on the creature from the moment the transport
touched down.
Having manifested as a hazy, humanoid outline,
SCP-1984 was making quick work of slaughtering
MTF Omega-59 and Sigma-18.
Nu-7 were able to intercept before it could
completely decimate their fellow operatives,
but now the Dead Hand had them pinned, stopping
the unit from accessing the on-site armory.
While they had all arrived loaded for bear,
the MTF operatives knew they couldn’t keep
SCP-1984 at bay for long with only their standard-issue
conventional weapons.
The entity’s only known weakness was microwave
radiation that could be emitted using specialized
weapons, if only they could access the Complex
04 armory.
Time is of the essence too, and the pressure
of stopping SCP-1984 quickly weighs heavily
on Private Hess.
He and the rest of Hammer Down know how the
entity operates, that it would be heading
just over eighty kilometers northwest at the
first chance it got.
If one too many of them were killed, or there
was a pause in the fighting for a second too
long, the Dead Hand would be on its way to
an installation nearby housing a number of
Intercontinental Ballistic Missiles.
Once there, it would waste no time, interfacing
with nuclear command systems, launching those
ICBMs, and causing catastrophic destruction.
1:30 PM
Deploying some quick thinking, Lieutenant
Patterson contacted Foundation command, and
had them send a secondary detachment of Nu-7
to the missile installation.
Part of their Mobile Task Force includes a
platoon of experts in various forms of warfare,
not just chemical and biological, but nuclear
too.
While that portion of Hammer Down were directed
to lock down the missile installation eighty
kilometers away, Patterson, Hess, and the
rest of Nu-7 were trying to distract SCP-1984.
Their engagement lasted around an hour, with
the entity attacking a number of the troops
on the ground.
Each one would suffer symptoms of intense
neurological trauma, including seizures and
the loss of cerebral spinal fluid from their
nose and eyes.
Experiencing it was painful enough, and the
sight of his fellow MTF agents dying in such
a horrific fashion wasn’t exactly what Private
Hess expected from his first day.
Eventually, SCP-1984 dissipates after a sustained
battle with Hammer Down, although it could
easily remanifest if it ever intercepts particular
broadcasts.
But the task forces’ work at Complex 04
is far from over.
After the battle comes the clean-up operation.
Private Hess follows orders from Patterson
to clear as much debris and as many bodies
as he can, making a note of every member of
their unit that they lost to the Dead Hand.
However, it doesn’t take long for the surviving
members of Nu-7 to receive another call for
assistance.
4:00 PM
Despite Hess’ concerns that he and the others
haven’t eaten in hours, the team loads up
and heads out again.
The Foundation has sent word that someone
has taken advantage of all the commotion at
Complex 04, and forced their way into a different
site.
Wasting no time, the remainder of Hammer Down
dusted off from the Sakha Republic, locking
and loading, ready to begin their next mission.
Arriving at the site, Foundation command radios
to Nu-7, updating them about the situation.
A large group of assailants, all members of
the Church of the Broken God, was midway through
launching an assault against the SCP Foundation.
Their goal was unclear, although the site
they had targeted was known to house SCP-882.
This anomaly is widely believed to be the
heart of the Broken God, a deity worshipped
by those of the Mekhanist faith.
One of the Church’s core goals was to repair
their god, as well as to enhance themselves
through mechanical, anomalous means.
Of course, this meant that a group of cyborg
cultists awaited the arriving task force.
Hammer Down clashes with the Church of the
Broken God, trying to divert them away from
the saltwater tank containing SCP-882.
Lieutenant Patterson warns them not to get
too close to the mass of welded metal, noting
that if the MTF troops’ weapons would become
fused to SCP-882.
Hearing that is what gives Hess the idea to
engage the cyborgs hand to hand.
Although the Church members were much stronger,
luring them closer to the heart of the Broken
God meant all their metallic enhancements
would also be pulled into SCP-882, killing
the devoted cultists, despite how pleased
they were to become one with their god, Mekhane.
7:00 PM
Moments of levity are often rare for Mobile
Task Forces.
Already it’s been a hell of a day, multiple
deployments and extremely high casualties.
For Private Hess, exhaustion is already setting
in; he’s been awake for over twelve hours,
barely survived encounters with a hostile
SCP and a tenacious Group of Interest.
And during each of the ensuing battles, he
has been made to watch as a number of his
fellow operatives die, some of them he’d
only just met.
Now he can barely recall their names.
Instead, as the day draws to a close, he prays
that he, Lieutenant Patterson, and the dwindling
remains of their squad won’t be called on
again… but this is the SCP Foundation, after
all.
8:00 PM
And whatever can go wrong, usually does – with
a gigantic, angry reptile in the middle of
it.
Sure enough, the alarms begin to sound, and
Private Hess has to get back to his feet.
He musters what fading scraps of energy he
can will back into his being, his weapon feeling
heavier than it has all day.
A tiny spike of adrenaline hits as Patterson
barks the fateful words Hess had hoped he
would never hear:
“On your feet, soldier!
SCP-682 is loose!”
Hammer Down races through the facility corridors,
passed by a flood of researchers all fleeing
for their lives.
The MTF team reaches the containment chamber,
just in time to witness SCP-682 – the infamous
Hard to Destroy Reptile – lunging at the
unfortunate personnel that couldn’t get
away in time.
Right next to Hess, one of his fellow Nu-7
teammates steps in a puddle of acid that has
spilled from the vat that usually houses the
murderous reptilian monster.
As the carnivorous SCP-682 finishes decimating
its previous target, it turns to angrily charge
for the MTF troops, who raise their weapons
and open fire, in what is ultimately a futile
attempt at stopping a creature that can’t
be harmed by mere bullets.
10:00 PM
Hours pass.
Containment breaches by SCP-682 are far from
an uncommon occurrence, and fortunately, the
Foundation’s task forces are more than used
to driving the creature back into its acid
tank, where it’s held only slightly more
securely.
But, with every escape attempt by the Hard
to Destroy Reptile comes a slew of casualties
from Foundation personnel.
And today is no exception.
Despite having sustained heavy injuries himself,
Lieutenant Patterson is instructed by his
superiors to file an end-of-day report before
he – and those that are still breathing
– can be debriefed.
The MTF lieutenant tallies up the considerable
losses his unit sustained on their various
engagements throughout the day, every operative
killed by the Dead Hand, then those that the
Church of the Broken God were able to make
quick work of, and of course, the ones who
met their demise at the hands – or rather
the jaws – of SCP-682.
The role of a Mobile Task Force operative
is a difficult and dangerous job.
But what few realize is how expendable these
troops are to the Foundation.
In fact, they’re not all that different
from D Class in that regard.
The SCP Foundation will simply throw their
most skilled agents into the fray, in the
hopes that enough of them will kill or contain
an anomalous threat no matter how many lives
it costs.
Perhaps nothing exemplifies that more than
the body of Private Killian Hess being wheeled
away for disposal after falling in the battle
with 682.
As if dying on his first day wasn’t bad
enough, the superior officers of MTF Nu-7
are already looking for a replacement to join
Hammer Down.
If this sounds like fun to you, apply today!
Now then, rookie, go and check out “SCP
ELITE MOBILE TASK FORCE EXPLAINED” and “How
to Work at the SCP Foundation Explained”
for more of the ins and outs of working for
the SCP Foundation!